let's say Y is equal to the natural log
of X to the X power and what we want to
do is we want to find the derivative of
Y with respect to X so I encourage you
to pause this video and see if you could
do it so when you first try to tackle
this this is a little bit daunting we
know how to take the derivative of
constants to some X power but how do we
take a derivative of some type of a
function in this case the natural log to
the X power and the answer here is to
use some of our logarithmic properties
and then we're going to do a little bit
of implicit differentiation so the first
thing that we want to do and actually
let me rewrite this with a little bit of
space so this was the natural log of X
to the to the X power so the first thing
I want to get rid of this as this X as
an exponential and I want to be able to
apply the product rule somehow and the
way we're going to do that is by taking
the natural log of both sides
so take the natural log of both sides
and you might say well why is that
helpful well if I'm taking the natural
log of something to an exponent well
this is the same thing actually let me
write this down as a property that you
may or might may or may not remember
from your logarithmic properties so if I
have I could write log or I'll just
write natural log of if I have natural
log of a to the B power this is the same
thing as B times the natural log of a
that's just a standard logarithmic
property and so by taking the natural
log of both sides this exponent can now
become out front and scale the natural
log function so this exponent now we can
bring that out front and let's just
rewrite everything so we get the natural
log of y is equal to so let me put that
and let me put that in parenthesis so
it's the natural log of y is equal to X
and that X is in blue x times the
natural log times the natural log of
sine x times the
natural log of the natural log of X the
natural log of the natural log of X so
there you have it by just taking the
natural log of both sides and using this
logarithmic property we were able to get
that now you're saying well well gee how
how is this actually going to be useful
for us
well now we can implicitly take the
derivative of both sides of this and
actually let me let me scoot this over
to the right a little bit just so that
we can I can I have space for my
derivative operator so there you go
glued that over and so now let's take
the derivative with respect to X of both
sides so let me so I'm going to take the
derivative with respect to X of the left
hand side and of the right hand side and
of the right hand side now on the left
hand side this is going to be
essentially an application of the chain
rule when you learn implicit
differentiation it's really just
application of the chain rule it's the
derivative of the outside function with
respect to the inside function so the
natural log of Y with respect to Y the
derivative of that is just going to be 1
over Y 1 over Y times the derivative of
the inside function with respect to X so
dy DX dy DX that is going to be equal to
well this is going to get interesting a
little bit actually let's let's let me
do some stuff on the on the side a
little bit just so well let me just the
first thing we want to do here is just
apply the product rule so it's the
derivative of the first expression so
it's just going to be 1 times the second
I guess you say function so times the
natural log of the natural log of X
natural log of X and then plus plus the
first function just x times the
derivative of the second function x
times the derivative of the second
function what's the derivative of the
natural log of the
natural log of X let's do that
separately so if I have if I'm trying to
take the derivative with respect to X of
the natural log the natural log of the
natural log of X of the natural log of X
well here again I can apply the chain
rule the derivative of that magenta
function with respect to the inside
function that is going to be 1 over the
natural log of X and then times the
derivative of the inside function with
respect to X so times 1 over X so this
is equal to 1 over X natural log of X so
the derivative of this second function
right over here is 1 over X natural log
of X 1 over X natural log of X let's see
that X and that X cancels out and so we
are left with we are left with 1 over Y
and I'll just I'll just write all of
this in this blue color so 1 over Y
times the derivative of Y with respect
to X is equal to C this is just the
natural log of the natural log of X the
natural log of the natural log of X plus
1 over the natural log of X 1 over the
natural log of X and now to solve for
the derivative we can multiply both
sides by Y so let's do that so we're
going to multiply that side by Y and
we're going to multiply this side times
y and what are we going to get well on
the left hand side that's why we
multiplied by Y we just have the
derivative of Y with respect to X
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to well Y is y is our original is
all this is our original thing that we
had Y was equal to the natural log let
me rewrite it over here Y was equal to
the natural log of X to the X power
so this is
essentially multiplying both sides times
the natural log of X to the X power so
this is going to get a little bit a
little bit messy here so we could write
it well we could just write it the way I
wrote it just now without it without it
being distributed actually let me just
leave it like that so it's going to be
and so we deserve our drumroll right now
because this is quite involved the
natural log of the natural log of X plus
1 over the natural log of X all of that
times the natural log of X to the X
power so that was quite involved and if
someone said well what is what is the
derivative of y when x is equal to e so
if someone says what is this equal to
when X is equal to e well we could
evaluate this when X is equal to e this
would be the and I know they didn't and
I just made that up just now so if like
the original question wasn't just what
is dy/dx if they said what is dy/dx when
X is equal to e if that was the original
question then we could evaluate it so
where we just replace all of these with
ease so be an e there and e there and E
there and an e there and I just picked
the value e because it's easy to
evaluate so the natural log of E is 1
natural log of 1 e to the 0 power is 1
so all of that just becomes 0 the
natural log of e is 1 so this whole
expression right over here becomes 0
plus 1 over 1 so it just becomes 1 and
then the natural log of e is the natural
log of e is 1 and you can have 1 to the
8th power well you could raise 1/2 to
any power and you're just going to get 1
so it's 1 times 1 is equal to 1 so I
just want that would be fun to try to
evaluate that at a edit value that would
be somewhat somewhat clean